David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 9-144B - the interview features Alfonsas Paulus or Paulis - this section was separated from Spool 144A, which contains the interview with Father Johan Kharchenko. This is Spool 9-144B Alfonsas Paulis, November the 9th, 1950, Boder.
David Boder: 20th September, 1946 at the Baltic camp at Lohengrinstrasse. The interview is the same that we started at Spool 143. Alfonsas Paulis, who was kind enough to relinquish his turn to the parson of the Greek Orthodoxian Church Johan Kharchenko. We are now returning to the interview of Mr. Alfonsas Paulis who is going to talk Lithuanian.
David Boder: [In German] Äh, noch mal also—jetzt sagen Sie, was hat Ihnen passiert von Neuem, wenn die Sowjets nach Litauen gekommen sind? Wo haben Sie gelebt und was hat Ihnen passiert? Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Paulis? Wie alt sind Sie?
Alfonsas Paulis: [In Lithuanian] Esu suvalkietis ir trumpai papasakosiu biški nuo keturiasdešimts trečių metų
David Boder: [In German] Langsam
Alfonsas Paulis: [In Lithuanian] kovo mėnesio septintos dienos iki keturiasdešimts penktų metų balandžio penktai iki amerikonam užėjus mus išlaisvinus. Mane, kaip žinot, aš esu paprastas darbinykas, mane areštavo už laikraščius, kurie, vadinasi, rašydavo prieš vokiečius, prieš fašizmą, prieš nacius. Areštavo geštapas, teko sėdėt...areštavo, teko sėdėt septintam forte, septintam forte, po tam...teko ir pabadaut, ten, kaip žinote, buvo tik vieni narai, buvom labai sumušti, tai yr, tai yra po žeme,
David Boder: [In German] Langsamer
Alfonsas Paulis: [In Lithuanian] Teko sėdėt tris savaites, paskuitės mus išvežė in Pravieniškį, Pravienišky toks buvo pradedamas konstracijos lageris. Tamkonstracijos lagery teko dirbt, dirbom miškuose. Ten prižiūriejo geštapiečiai, jie mus labai mušdavo lazdom, valgyt mažai gaudavom, laukėm vis, kada bus gerau. Nu, vieną kartą gaunam žinią, kad reik visiem pasiruošt, naktį išveža kur tai. Veža mus in Vokietiją, suvaro in vagonus, užkala vagonus, dratais apraišoja spygliuotais, visur sargybiniai apstoja, veža...o mes gaunam cinešt gi pjūklų, turėjome pjūklą, peilių, ir sugalvojom bėgt. Davažuojam kada Vokiečių sieną, tai yra Kybartai, pjaunam, bandom pjaut, tik sustoja traukinys, mes manėm, kad nestos, spėsim papjaut, išpjauti ir galėsim išbėgt in miškuos. Bet tas viskas neįvyko, mum nepasi...apžiūrėjo, mus...apžiūrėjo, kad mes pjaunam, sustabdė traukinį ir leido po vieną iš traukinio, ir bitkom mus vokiečiai išrεngė iki pusės nuogus ir mušė, buvo tokios bitkos bubinės, iš telefono darytos, po kiekvieną leido, pirmiausia man pačiam teko iš to vagono lipt, tai dėl to aš daugiausiai gavau pilt, mat buvau kaipodidžiausias kaltinykas, nes aš buvau atsinešęs tą pjūklą. Paskuitės mus išrεngė iki pusiau nuogus ir liepė—paduoda bitkąman ir draugui ir liepė vienas kitą mušti...nu...draugo gaila, nemuši, tai jis prišoka, ir jisai buvo tep sako duok, taip pats raičiojasi negyvas, tiesiog žmonės eina civyliai ir slopsta moterys žiūrεdamos.
David Boder: [In German] Bisschen aus bis Zeit, gerade, hierhin..
Alfonsas Paulis: [In Lithuanian] Turεjom biški maisto kaip kas, dar vežėmės žinoma, Lietuvoj galėjo priduoti, dar kaip kam atsiųsdavo biški, atėmė iš mus maistą visą, suvarė atgal in vagonus, paskuitės vežė toliau. Vežė mus apie keturas paras. Nieko nedavė nei valgyt, nei gert. Tada daugiau užkalė, daugiau sargybinių pribuvo, labiau užkalė tuos vagonus, atvežė mus net in Francūziją. Sustoja kur, ne vandenio prašom, neduod nė vandenio, nė valgyt, taip ir vežė. Atvežė, išėmė daug lavonų Francūzijoj negyvų. Nežinau, kur tai, tos vietovės, bet maždaug prie francūzų tos mažino linijų, mus išlaipdino, suvarė in tokį lagerį, tam lagery davė biški sriubos užvalgyt, po tam pernakvojom. Ant ryt išvežė in darbus, išvežė in darbus, prie sunkių darbų, kur mes tiesėm požeminį tokį kabelį, kab elektrą būk tai yra tam kabely, nešiojom po laukus, po miškus, kirtom grovius. Kada tep jau pavasarį, jau buvo biški šiltoka, sugalvojom...valgyt neduoda, utelių pilni, kad baisu pažiūrėt tiesiog, miegot negaunam, vienuoliktą valandą gulam, pirmą valandą jau keliam, visokie patikrinimai, pabėgo vienas, antras, nusprendžiau ir aš bėgt. Nu ir vieną kartą pabėgu iš miško iš sargybinių ir bėgu. Bėgu apie keturas paras, žinoma, kad Vokietijoj, nieko neprieisi, nieko nepaprašysi, kožnas vaikas mažiausias ir tai atpažįsta, tu, sako, banditas. Tai ką, man teko gyvent: buvo pasodintos bulvės, tai kasiau iš lauko bulves, radau tokiam kelmyne degė tokis uždegtas durpynas, ten pasikepiau tų bulvių, užvalgiau ir taip toliau, atsigeriu vandeniu, ir bėgu. Ir pribėgau—man nežinoma kokioj vietoj, nežinomam miestely, ir ima mane pagauna žandarai. Nu, nuo to laiko mane ištardo, paskaito mane šnipas, ir pasodina mane į štraflagerį...štraflagerį. Tas štraflageris buvo taip vadinasi niekeno žemėj tarpu francūzų ir vokiečių linijos, ir man ten nuteisė sėdėti dvidešims devynias paras. O ten jau kap mažiau kas gaudavo, tai mažiau laikydavo. Ten prižūrεjo geštapiečiai, jie buvo daugiausia vokiečiai, ir besarabai, kaip juos vadino, tai tiesiog žmogų muša, užmuša ir juokiasi. Tai gaudavom valgyt pusę litro tokios žolės papjautos in dieną ir šimtą gramų duonos, ir kavos dukart in dieną. Ten dirbt nerεikdavo, labai mažai rεikdavo dirbt, bet vaiko gult, kelt ir klupsčiom eit, ir muša, kad mano per savaitę laiko tai sutino rankos ir kojos, buvau nepanašus į žmogų, jai sakiau, manau, sudie šitas pasaulis. Bet šiaip taip išlaikiau, kada iš tenai mane pervežė Natzweiler lager. Natzweiler lager kiek buvo panašiau, jis buvo tokiuose kalnuose, miškuose. Ir tenai jau pradėjo varyt in darbus, ten aprangė drabužiais, tokiais civyliškais, bet tie drabužiai nuplyšę, be baltinių, tik su vienom kelnėm, teko būt, o ant tų svarkų tai buvo mūsų maliavotas raudonas kryžius, per rankoves ėjo lempasai, per kelnės irgi lempasai, o apsiaut buvom gavę mediniais padais, tokios brezantinės šliūrės, kur ant galų pirštų vos tik laikydavosi. Tai išvaro in darbus, tekt dirbdavo sunkiai. Dirbom su karučiais, veždavom akmenis, žemes ir taip toliau, visokias šiukšles, tenai tuose kalnuose, ir tokius kelius dirbom. Nu, valdyt gaudavom mažai, keldavom baisiai anksti, išvaro, anksti rytą prikelia, trečią valandą, antrą valandą, tai išvaro pirmiausia vienmarškinius, ant to rajono, mus vaiko, vaiko ratą, paskui parvaro kavos pagert, po tai paskui varo in darbus, tai duoda kavos, pageri, gaunam šimtą gramų duonos, ant jau...einam in darbą, tai duoda šimtą gramų duonos ir biški užtepta margarino, tokį bruceidą tokį vadinamąjį, dešimtai valandai valgyt. Nu, nuvaro ten mus dirbt, ten gyveno karuomenė—esesai, ten lupinėt tokių lupynų,ką nuštveri, tą valga tas lupynas, valgo žolę iš bado, ką gi žmogus darysi. Valgai viską. Tai dabartis pamatė mane kapo—tokie buvo specialiai kapo paskirti, vadinas tokie išgyvėję žmonės, kurie labai mušdavo, mušdavo-kankindavo. Ir jie patys prieš esesus rεikia eit ir kepurę neštis rankoje, jeigu nusiėmei kepurę, tai jis atėjo ir tau per galvą duoda lazda ar kuom papuola, kum jis dar turi, arba šautuvu. Tai aš turėjau bruceitą tą, ir jis pas mane apžiūrėjo po dešimtai valandai dar tos bruceitos nesuvalgęs, tai jis man tą bruceitą, sako, kas čia dabar pas tave kišenėj, ištraukė tą bruceitą, jis man per burną, mane sukruvino ton bruceiton, tą bruceitą aš renku nuo žemės, masinai biro kraujai, jis atėjęs kojom mane spardo. Ką tu, sako, dirbi, rokuoja, lupynuos sėdi ir bruceituo, o bruceitą šone turi. O aš—ką aš, neėsiu? Aš ėdu lupynas ir viską, manau tos bruceitos biški toliau bus, o da čia nustvėriu lupynų, bet lupynų negaliu gaut. Tai valgau lupynas, ką pirmomis turiu—kopūsto lapą žalią, tą valgai. Jis mane sudaužo, sudaužo ir dar nutraukė, rokuoja, paėsi ir pietų negausi. Parėjau namo, negaunu pietų, laukiu tik vakaro, po tam...nu, buvo kiek laiko, teišdirbau, buvo kas tai—ar vakacija kokia, ar tai frontas artėjo, ar tai kas...Mus iševokavo visus in Dachavo konstracijos lagerį. O Dachave buvau uždarytas iš kap vadino buvo Dacavo konstracijos lageris ir buvo Štrabna paskui lageris, tokis atskiras, nubaustas, nubaustų nubaustas, karantinos blokais vadino, tai buvo užtverami, nieko nebuvo matyt, tik blokas nuo bloko buvo kap per šešis metrus, iš galų žkalta aukštai lentom, barakai mediniai, pilni buvo blakių, utelių, gulėjom ant tik vienos lovos, po keturis, po penkis žmones, utelių buvo pilna, ir kasdien mirdavo, prie šono po du, po tris lavonus išnešdavo ryte, kol eisi—eisi in prausyklą, eisi in išvietę, - visur lavonų rasi pilna, lauke guli tiesiog krūvos, nepanašūs jau lavonai į žmones, bet tiesiog yra jau į šakalius taip sudžiūvę, kad baisu žiūrεt. Pagalvoji, bet tos mirtės nebaisu, bet parokuoji, tas kankinimas. Taip gyvenom visą laiką—pusiau nuogi, išvaro, nepaspėji išeit sriubos atsiimt perpiet—negavai ne tik kad tos sriubos, bet dar negavai vakarienės, arba iš ryto prikelia anksti, išvaro nuogus, ant sniego, ant sniego, o tai koks patikrinimas, užėjo kas tai vėl kokis jie sugalvoj ką nors, taip tep drūšydavo, tai tep, ko nepaspėjai, tai tau per galvą davė, nusiverti, muša, kankina, kiek jie išmano. Nu, paskuitės tep sėdėjom, laukėm užlėkės, kada pasibaigs karas, manom vis kada sulauksim, kada belaukiant lėktuvai bombarduoja aplink, nebijom, kad užmušt artodo kad tik mažu greičiau pasibaigs karas, pasibaigs tų prakeiktų gyvybę, prakeiktų gyvenimui, kada ateis vis tiek galas. Tada belaukiant keturasdešims penktais metais taip balandžio devintą mεnesį, tai tiesa, buvo dar užminuotas buvo visas lageris, ir apie devintą valandą, kiek turεjom žinių, būtum vakare buvę išsprogdintas visas lageris. Bet viens atsirado kas tai kokis žinojo kas tas yra, pranešė amerikonų karuomenei, ir karuomenė paskubino užimt Dachavą ir mus išlaisvint. Ir tada išlaisvino mus iš to Dachavo, ačiū Amerikos karuomenei už tai, kad mus išlaisvino.
David Boder: [In Russian] колько времени вы теперь здесь?
David Boder: [In German] Wieviel Zeit sind Sie hier jetzt? In äh- in äh - Esklave?
Alfonsas Paulis: [In Russian] По-русски, по-русски
David Boder: По-русски
David Boder: Сколько времени вы уже здесь в этом лагере?
Alfonsas Paulis: В этом лагере...
Alfonsas Paulis: [In Lithuanian]...nuo...nuo...šitam lagery aš gyvenu nuo keturasdešims penktų metų balandž...gegužės mεnesio apie dvidešimtos dienos.
David Boder: [In Russian] У вас родственники в Америке есть?
Alfonsas Paulis: [In Lithuanian] Turu Amerikoj brolį...turu brolį ir brolio yra sūnus viens kuni
David Boder: [In Russian] Два брата?
Alfonsas Paulis: Брат
David Boder: А где он?
Alfonsas Paulis: Вот я не могу вам сказать этого
David Boder: Не знаете, где
Alfonsas Paulis: Я знаю, письмо я получил
David Boder: Ага, вы получили
Alfonsas Paulis: получил
Alfonsas Paulis: Yra brolio sūnus yra kunigas yra Najauke
David Boder: Ага, и он что, вам пошлёт афадавит
Alfonsas Paulis: Нет, я давно получил его.
David Boder: Ага
Alfonsas Paulis: [In Lithuanian] Ir turu dvi tetas
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага
Alfonsas Paulis: [In Lithuanian] Dar va ką tik susirašiau
David Boder: [In Russian] Что-нибудь ещё вы хотите сказать?
Alfonsas Paulis: Больше ничего
David Boder: Ну во, спасибо тогда
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Alfonsas Paulis, September 21st 1946, Munich, Lohengrinstrasse, displaced peoples camp for the Baltics, eh..in the camp where there are detained Lithuanians, Latvians and Estonians.